[Music]
hey everyone I'm ash Crossin but more
importantly is the man sitting next to
me Peyton Reed the director of man and
the wasp hello hello how's it going it's
great what a fantastic movie thank you
have so many great things to say about
it but what I love about you is you're
very good at portraying women on screen
and watching ant-man on the wasp was not
the first time in Marvel but like one of
the I think rare times where I'm
watching a woman on screen that doesn't
feel like shoehorned into the movie was
that like a specific specific
conversations you had with the you know
Hannah and Evangeline or is do you feel
like there's someone in your life that
really lends to like how you I think you
just for a man the wasp it made sense
yeah particularly with what we had set
up in the first movie where Evangeline's
character hope is clearly the better
qualified in the first movie to deal
with hank pym situation but she's not
allowed to by her father because I think
you know he's being overly protective he
doesn't want her to meet the same fate
that the Janet met so when it came time
to do this it just seemed like the thing
well this is gonna be ant-man and the
wasp it's not gonna be ant-man - its
ant-man the wasp because in the comics
you know when I used to read like that
was the thing that the sort of Hank
jannat era they were a partnership and
it felt like that was the logical way to
go with with this movie and then having
decided that that it'd be a thing where
it's not you know a man's the star and
she's a supporting character they're
both leads in the movie yeah like she
wasn't his sidekick and you know yeah or
the other way around it was like and if
anything we kind of like waited a little
more towards hope
that felt right to all of us yeah and I
think it's um it's something where I
wanted to work really closely with
Evangeline from story through script on
about dimensionalizing this character as
much as we could and it went from little
tiny things like Evangeline was very
specific about you know if I have a
flight team I don't I don't want to come
out with like perfect hair and nails I
want to sweat right I want to have my
hair in a very practical ponytail so
that helmet comes on and off and I want
it to feel as real as we can in this
context and we talked a lot not only
about how she fought and moved but just
her whole attitude about being a hero
which is very different than Scotland
hold on
you gave her wings and blasters was
there ever like a conversation about
just calling it the wasp because I think
a lot of people tweeted that instantly
after their yeah after seeing the movie
I think there were conversations about
it I don't know that they lasted very
long it just seemed like again because
of their history in the comics that
ant-man the wasp felt right and I have
to say to Paul Rudd was all in on that I
mean cuz I could imagine that there are
plenty of male actors who might have
been uncomfortable with that progression
I I hope I never work with any of them
but the idea that like you know you
could easily imagine somebody like wait
a second this is my move is my franchise
you know just she's Horning in on my
thing and Rudd's the opposite that Rudd
just got it and that's you know is
something we clearly seeded into the
first movie and I think he has fun with
the idea that she's you know she's
committed to being a hero at the
beginning of the movie he's not ant-man
he's not sure he wants to continue being
a man because it's brought such
complication to his life but you know
that was something that that he really
loved we had talked about this before
and it's like one of my favorite things
is you say when Paul Rudd went in did
civil war he's like well now I'm in a
real Marvel movie yeah and it almost
felt like there was some parts with
Evangeline character that were your
voice a little bit of everything like Oh
Jeff Vaughn over there I ain't thought
about that but maybe yeah maybe I get
personal me that's actually really yeah
I think that's probably right
the wasp teaming up you introduced some
new characters and fulfilled our
antagonist Hannah John Comyn
playing ghost I absolutely loved her and
I think that it's not a secret that
Marvel had like a little bit of a
criticism about villains and having kind
of a quote unquote villain problem but I
think there's been a lot of movies
lately that have had really compelling
complex villains yeah and she's one of
them so just kind of snowballing on top
of that yeah what is it about her that
you think makes her kind of so
compelling well I think it's a couple of
things when we set out to design just
the structure and the story of this
movie we talked about kind of having
this Elmore Leonard esque by where there
was a very simple goal that our heroes
had and a lot of antagonists and
complications along the way and for us
that meant there wasn't this giant
towering you know fan oasw's like
villain but there was gonna be a main
antagonist and it was ghosts and we
adapted that character who was a man in
the comics and it just felt right to
create we were free to reinvent her
origin as much as we wanted to and we
all like from the beginning that you
know she was a very formidable foe but
you could also really empathize with
this character because she's a victim
and she's you know this amazing power
set that she has is as much an
affliction as it is a benefit for her
when we found Hannah you know Hannah
read for the role and she just had this
first of all she has this amazing look
she's the most striking looking person
she has and there's mystery to her look
which I think really felt right for this
character and in the in the first
reading in her audition she just had
this ferocity that the character
required but also this vulnerability in
those scenes that was really compelling
and we like that she was not this actor
that everybody knew she was more of a
discovery and I think that really it fit
in well with the ant-man world you
mentioned my wife again and I'll show
you porosity Michael Douglas recently
gave an interview but then you know he's
kind of gone back and forth on this but
he supposedly said he wants to do a
prequel ant-man I read this yeah yeah
yeah we asked her that and then he was
like I don't I don't know that I said
that yeah is that something that
interests you at all well I think I
think first of all Michael was very
intrigued from the first movie and and
this one with this whole d aging process
it's
by the way and it's it's like crazy
brilliant like I think sometimes like in
movies I get a little distracted by that
sport and in this one with with both the
characters that got happens I'm like oh
my god well you've seen the movie and
there are so many visual effects in the
movie because over 1,800 visual effects
shots yeah and still the most terrifying
one is that D aging effect because I've
stupidly chosen to do it on you know the
most identifiable well-known actors I'm
Michael Douglas Michelle Pfeiffer and
there's a bit with Laurence Fishburne
too yeah everybody knows what they look
like thirty years ago so when you're in
there and doing the process you get that
weird uncanny valley thing if it's
slightly off it's like oh it literally
like moves the audience away from the
movie so this company Lola who does it
they're just they're geniuses and they
sort of they take their time as they
should and those are generally the last
finished effects that we get which is
also terrifying because we're starting
the movie with that but I think they did
amazing work so Michael was very from
the first movie on entry with that
process and I suppose you could do a
young Michael and Michelle ant-man and
wasps anemia but the technical
considerations of it are so to do that
for every shot of the movie would be it
would make my head explode yeah yeah
[Music]